en somme votre problème est que vous
pensez que la meilleure préparation un
ménage un couple réussie et d'avoir si
vous voulez les expériences sexuelles
avant le mariage tout à fait je trouve
ça absolument aberrant qu'on se marie ce
sans se connaître et se connaître c'est
ce que connaître aussi bien moralement
que physiquement le point elle se pose
parce que il ya aucune raison que ce
soit y en a 18 ans et pas 21 ans on
n'est pas le droit d'être heureux alors
là je crois peut-être que vous n'êtes
pas dans la vérité non je ne crois pas
et je ne crois pas que ce soit une bonne
préparation à une vie conjugale heureuse
et épanouie était de mettre la charrue
avant les boeufs voyez-vous deux jeunes
qui considèrent que pendant les
fiançailles faut avoir une union totale
je crois assez comme des enfants qui
aimant la tarte aux cerises veulent la
manger avant qu'elle aille au four